but what attracts you to amanda like
well there's a couple different mating
strategies that women look for so like
one um is resources when it comes to
like money
and um
resources as in he'll stick around and
invest in the child so like girls can
kind of feel like what guy is more of
like a father one is gene so that's
things like height
facial symmetry
strength that sort of thing another one
is legacy
it will he embarrass the family
another one is i always forget the fifth
i put in the chat what the fifth one is
but yeah there's just different mating
strategies that girls but like in
language terms there's out and i hate
these terms but
shout out rolo okay alpha alpha alpha
fox beta bucks and there's the guy
that's like the girl's super attracted
to and she like sleeps with super soon
and there's there's the
guy that she makes wait and she wants to
take care of her
yeah cool and
like girls will look for both but like a
guy with both is rare yeah
and he'll probably cheat on you
because he's rare
and then but the thing is like and we've
spoken about this so many times like
women generally want the same type of
men
and so the reason why you get baby mamas
nowadays fighting over the same guy is
because those guys are breeding with all
of the women
right that's why all the baby members
are fighting over this one guy this one
guy's got three four women pregnant so
he's got he's got women
those women know exactly what he's like
yeah they know exactly what he's like
and they choose to breed him because he
has those traits and that's the thing
like a lot of girls are sleeping with
ben that aren't fathers
and they and
they're sleeping with men that aren't
fathers like they're not sorry they're
not husbands i should say better better
term um and they know they're not
husbands and they're sleeping with them
and they get pregnant by them and then
you know they're shocked when he's not a
husband no but you said get pregnant she
chose to get yes you know i agree i
agree you're right bad bad word right so
now we're getting to it now so now we're
getting to it you know that guy
doesn't want you like how you want him
you trap him to have your child
and you you try to lock him down
not knowing that you trapping him is not
going to lock him down
you think by you having a baby with him
it stops other girls from having a baby
with him but they just see and see as i
want to have a baby with him as well
yeah cool because
it's pretty it's pre-selection so like
biologically women are predispositioned
to i mean not personally i'm i'm i don't
do the whole kids thing but but
but in general like like um
not me and i don't need that but
but but like genetically we are
biologically predispositioned to like
men that other women want so if another
women woman gave him a baby it signals
to us that he can take care of us too
right of course yeah my dad just told me
don't do so are you a virgin
no i'm not a virgin so would you mean
you don't do the baby thing then i don't
i don't want to date a guy with kids
oh i thought you meant you have a baby
no i don't have a kid
why not would you wait pearl hasn't got
any children yeah no no children you
don't want any children no i want a lot
of kids that's something to say i'm
saying i don't date guys with children
yeah that's not because she wants to
build her own yeah because i just feel
like like that's something that i really
want
like me
i i really want me and my husband to
be
you like black men
hey hey what's going on here no no i'm
just saying basically i saw on another
podcast
50 of black men are single and childless
in the middle class yeah but why would i
why would i pick the ones with kids
because
like no because he's had a kid before so
he might know how to look after the kids
better but
he's selling himself right now
you got kids as well man i'm telling you
you're
it's been really important to me to have
like a stable family unit and that's
just something that's really important
to me two parents in the home i don't
want baby mama drama i don't want any of
that i just want two parents in the home
we both have the first kid together and
i don't think it's really smart to
advise girls to go after guys with kids
i think that's like a lot of the
problems we're seeing so do you want to
get married before you have a kid yeah
that's what that's the way to do it yeah
that's what that's the way to do it like
honestly if you get married first
a man feels more obliged to stay with
the woman i don't i don't know why you
think it's the other way around like not
the other way around as well
bro listen
are you gonna get down on your on is she
going to get down on her knee or are you
going to get down on your knee
you're getting down on your knee so that
means you've already committed to what
you're going to do right yeah but don't
you think that's because they're
frightening divorce and they think oh
well you know she's going to take her
assets
yeah so i mean it's like it's pretty
expensive to get a prenup you got 10k
laying around i mean if you're gonna
risk half of your wealth going then i
should have 10k laying around if i'm
going to have a white dress and a ring
i'm saying that's the reason a lot of
guys don't do it is it is expensive um
and i just know this because i have a
couple friends that have gone through
the process and they just like the the
cost didn't
make sense to them is that what you're
going to tell your potential husband
what i mean personally personally um
like i i want to prenup like on my end
obviously
but the thing is i i just don't think
it's wise to advise
i think people with kids should just
date each other you guys can do it do
you see what do you see why now men
wanted to have pre
it's so funny how when women start to
make money now they start to understand
oh this is why you wanted to preach the
thing i've always said i would sign a
prenup yeah i've always said that not
you pro
but i don't i don't really understand
why girls marriage is not about romance
that's one of the major things that
people don't understand marriage is a
contract between two people to do
something it's not generally about
romance in
before it became this i would romance
this fantasy this fantasy it was about
the coming together of two families
right for a specific reason right and
the two people would marry and they
would basically they would
they would become a conglomerate now do
you know what i mean it's not about it's
not about it's not about love and that's
that's what i think people get wrong
and because when you think about it
you're going to be with someone let's
say i get married you know let's say
let's say we get married at 30 right
well me and you
let's say
um me and somebody
get married at 30. i'm gonna live to
probably be 80 90. that's 50 60 years
like are you really going to love them
all 50 60 years like there are times
when my parents didn't get along but i'm
glad that they stayed together because
i would hate to do two christmases and i
would hate to like have that all split
up
love is not based on just feeling it's
principle it's a choice it's a choice
it's a verb
as long as that's part of it it makes it
easy it's like having medicine that's
got sugar in it some of it is bitter but
the sweet one's easier to go down
emotions are fickle love is a commitment
it's not just about the feeling so when
you're going to get married it's love
not a feeling yeah it's part that's part
of it that's part of it but that's only
a small part of it it's a combination of
things it's like a it's a paradox
are you saying this duty yeah that's
part of it too yeah but obviously you
have the feeling duty principle
long-suffering sacrifice these are all
parts of it but people only want to take
the parts that they like that's the
problem i need to ask you that doesn't
mean your parents didn't love each other
because they had arguments
yeah no i know that's just that's what
i'm saying but i saw a lot of like i had
friends parents that also argued growing
up and they ended up getting a divorce
and i see them like 10 20 years down the
line and they regret it
because it was it would have been better
for the kids and then like i mean you
put
um i just looked up this